apresurados hacen todo lo posible para
evitar que el fuego consuma a su
comunidad residentes de chop que teme en
la provincia de mula ayudan a los
bomberos presentes mientras el fuego
avance en el séptimo día de incendios
que consumen al menos cuatro provincias
del sur de turquía mula ubicada en el
suroeste del país ha sido de las
provincias más afectadas residentes
reclaman la falta de presencia estatal
para controlar los masivos incendios
el estado no está ayudando sin la gente
del pueblo sería peor no hay suficientes
bomberos no hay aviones no hay
helicópteros las altas temperaturas y
fuertes vientos contribuyen a los peores
incendios registrados en una década con
95 mil hectáreas quemadas según cifras
oficiales
tratamos de proteger nuestras casas con
nuestros medios llenando cubetas nos
organizamos con vecinos jóvenes y
salvamos nuestros hogares el
departamento de bomberos no fue capaz de
intervenir
de hecho agotaron sus baterías
encendiendo sean luces de techo nadie
vino a regar agua alrededor de nuestras
nos dejaron solo la unión europea'
movilizó hidroaviones de croacia y
españa para extinguir las llamas aviones
de rusia azerbayán irán y ucrania
también brindan apoyo ya que el gobierno
turco no contaba con hidroaviones
disponibles cuando los incendios
comenzaron